Mark Steyn is an author and a columnist
he joins us tonight mark are you
surprised by these numbers no I'm not
because I think it accords with most
people's experience of the
transformative effect of immigration and
it's logical to that when a first world
country imports continuously a large
unskilled population into its country
illegally that is and that that is an
act of law breaking at the conception
and there's no reason why they would
then have any other respect for other
laws and to be honest I mean I I found
that last five minutes surreal where you
know that your guests main concern is
that certainly legal immigrants are are
getting crimes committed against them by
other illegal immigrants and they're
scared to go to the police that's not
what the statistics show these
statistics which for political
correctness reasons we were prevented
from knowing in recent years show that
this country is in effect importing a
criminal class and it ban it does not
check any aspect of the criminal class
at import now that the few of us who
have the misfortune to go through the
legal immigration system I went to see
Neil at Homeland Security in Manchester
New Hampshire a couple years ago and he
asked me about whether I'd committed any
crimes and I said I'd been pulled over
by a traffic cop in Montpelier Vermont
for passing a little old lady at 17
miles an hour but I got the case
dismissed Neal from homeland security in
Manchester New Hampshire wanted to see
proof that the state of Vermont had
actually dismissed that complaint
against me so we have a bifurcated
system here in which law-abiding people
have to dot every I and cross every T
and every single day we import drug
gangs money launderers murderers drug
drivers because the professional lobby
group your previous guests represent
somehow thinks this is in the interests
of the United States it's not at all the
rector of my church spent the better
part of a year waiting for a visa you
spent 20 years in the British Army they
didn't want any more Scottish Anglicans
in this country because they're
dangerous meanwhile all of Congress is
arguing now we can keep people who snuck
in illegally here and you're a bigot if
you're not for that so it's so what does
this reduce oh so like the key argument
has always been that immigrants are
better than we are I mean isn't that the
argument you hear every day like they
commit fewer crimes than you do they
work harder
there's better people how dare you
complain about them now that we know
these crime rates are way higher than
they are for American native-born what's
what's their argument now well well
Nancy Pelosi has said that we ought to
thank the parents of the dreamers for
bringing them here because as you say
they're better than us if you listen to
people at your previous guests every
single dreamer is a high school
valedictorian just wrapping up his third
tour of Afghanistan they're way better
than us so the only way to get the
general depravity rate down in the
United States is to import more and more
low-skilled immigrants illegally across
the Rio Grande that's the argument Jorge
Ramos may know you're much safer being
in a town of illegal immigrants than you
are in a town who say whose population
got off the Mayflower and the fact of
the matter is this is absolutely the
inverse of the truth the statistics you
cited even taken as a whole 94% of these
non citizen criminals in federal custody
and by the way this is just the tip of
the iceberg because 90% of incarceration
is at the state and local level but the
proportions show that about 94% of these
non citizen criminals in US federal
prison are illegal immigrants why does
any country need to import a criminal
class if that is one of the jobs that
Americans will do Americans are happy to
murder and rape and sell drugs to each
other you don't need to import other
people to do that yeah well one job that
Americans are less in
trusted in his voting democrat and these
are people who will do that so that's
kind of the point that's kind of the
point of the whole thing
mark Stein thank you yes that's right
thanks a lot merry Christmas to you
Merry Christmas thank you